really is the more incredible in us
right now thank you like we were the
second runner and his energy that comes
off you is just it's it's like you have
an aura that goes for miles
thank you you have this incredible
energy that is I think I'm feeling I
think that most people aren't as
grateful as I am I really believe that I
really think when I think about my
energy I think it's just gratitude I
really do
perspective yeah like I just it's I
really struggle I really struggle with
being upset about what everybody spends
her time being upset about like losing
an account or or having somebody make
fun of you or like just like like it's
just really hard to get upset about
things other than the health of the 11
people I give a [ __ ] about and then so
everything else is gets just binary it's
that's what's worth being upset about
and then everything else is awesome
you know they watching so much of you
like this is it it's so cool yeah I
can't believe how cool this room has
become until like entrepreneurs and soap
makes me so obvious it's not Connie yeah
yeah so you know we're like we're like
the 40 plus year old people who started
I got it with entrepreneurs yeah we've
both been speakers in schools and
universities around Australia for like
17 years yes teenagers yes and parents
so we create content for parents yes
content for teenagers to help them get
through that you know they're really
tough I so I talk about drugs alcohol
safe partying night clubbing you know
when they go out keeping themselves safe
and I talked about Crees bullying cyber
bullying stress management body image
teamwork yes let's go let's get right
into it oh it's going so all right so
tell us it's tell us who you are yes
your stories
I'm Gary Vaynerchuk my story is a
classic American immigrant story I was
born in Belarus in the former Soviet
Union I came here when I was a little
kid I lived in a studio apartment the
size of the office we're in with six
family members seven family members
depending on the day of the week
extremely humble beginnings didn't speak
the
language got picked on because I didn't
speak the language but then had an
amazing childhood we very quickly my dad
worked his butt off and became a manager
of a liquor store which allowed us and
afforded us to move out to Edison New
Jersey and there I became an
entrepreneur well I played plenty of
wiffle ball and nerf football and and
you know a lot of games but I spent an
uncut in hindsight I spent it on godly
amount of time on car washes on lemonade
stands on raking leaves on singing
Christmas carols anything to make a
dollar anything and so and that led to
baseball cards which then led to a very
successful entrepreneurial career in the
wine business which is my dad's business
in investing you know Tumblr and Twitter
and uber stocks or hanging around here
and I invested in those pretty IPO and
now we're sitting in vaynermedia you
know which is a 150 million dollar
agency and then obviously along the way
I've also built out a personal brand
that's led to what's about to be my
fifth New York Times bestselling book
and and a career where I'm getting I
mean the fact that I get paid more to
give a one-hour speech today than I made
for the whole year just you know 15
years ago it's just scary exciting and
so that's been fun and as you guys know
have really inspired an interesting
conversation amongst a lot of people a
slightly you know a slightly different
take I think on what is motive you know
I don't think of myself as a
motivational speaker but I'm clearly a
personality that has been able to get
people to get results which you can't
imagine how proud of I am what kind of
teen actually I was a great teenager my
mom I'm writing a book called perfectly
parented so it's interesting to hear
what you guys so I'm writing a book
called perfectly parented and it's the
perspective of a kid who feels his
parents perfectly parented him
my mom and dad picked so I never did any
I mean I did nothing wrong except get
bad grades so I I never disrespected
anybody I never did cliched drugs and
alcohol stuff I was I was a nice
kid I was friends with everybody in my
high school I worked every minute I went
to like seven high school parties in my
life you know I just worked
I like helped around the house because I
was the oldest I was I was a
ridiculously good kid yet I wasn't like
a square or you know like meaning I had
fun I enjoyed it like my luck my high
school years were very simple I worked
every minute ohright which was the
happiest moments of my time whether it
was doing baseball card shows selling at
flea markets or working in my dad's
liquor store or I was in school being
miserable I didn't play sports I played
tennis for two years but I barely played
sports I I didn't chase girls for the
most part like I just was very focused
on being an entrepreneur from a very
young age and I was obsessed with not
making my mom upset yeah you know it's
just true like I my mom guilted me into
being a great child and a great teenager
and I think that's what I do to my
employees
by providing so much loved and and
support that the fear is letting them
down guilty
Irish was gonna leave after working for
a year that was her plan that was her
thoughts but she's still here because
it's better to be here than it's not to
be here well a lot of teenagers actually
disconnect from their parents because
their parents are screwing up their
parents are doing the wrong thing their
parents care about themselves not their
kids parents are struggling out there
because they're insecure and their
parenting their children based on the
judgment of other parents not based on
putting their kids in this position to
succeed so you never disconnected from
your parents that you need
I want to reconnect into my parents
right now I love them so much I won't
live with my parents now but you have to
understand why my mom's entire framework
was supporting me not she was in a
cocoon my mom didn't give a [ __ ] what
another parent thought about me she's
self-confidence you self-confidence yeah
I mean I don't know because my mom lost
her mom at five she grew up in Soviet
Russia which is a very negative place it
was just in her she was a it was a DNA
trait maybe it was over correction for
not having a mom she wanted to be the
best but I don't have a really deeply
psychoanalyzed my mom yet but you know
she she why did she do a good job and I
think you know again I think I think the
reason I'm popular as a personality is
cuz I'm better to my audience than
anybody else I don't want to trick you
into anything
that's what you feel on stage you know
why you felt it it's cuz I genuinely
want you to win there's nothing else
because it's a legacy it's like being a
parent you being successful is an
incredible indication of me but I think
most people that are motivational
speakers personalities are running
businesses are selfishly in it for
what's in it for them in the short term
yeah what's almost likely thing is an
iOS sound just the visible for the
information to come out to be able to go
get to you but but I will I but I'm also
selfish like I don't think I'm some
altruistic kind of like you know vessel
I'm selfish my selfishness comes in the
form of legacy I have a funny feeling
you guys aren't flying from Australia to
New York for most people seriously not
well well well we are doing it for a lot
of other people as yes I'm sure doing it
fast because it feels - it feels right
you know what I mean is you're not gonna
get dragged out are you somewhere I
understand what I what I mean is
basically my very simple thesis is I
will win yes if I have the
Delta between being financially
successful and having the most people
come to my funeral yeah I have no
interest in building a 14 billion dollar
empire and having four people at my
funeral I would much rather do 400
million and have 40,000 people show up
to my funeral
I think legacy is far more attractive
than currency and and that's what my mom
created like she took she gave up the
short term judgment I was a DNF student
Tyler is my report card coming good I'm
gonna hang that neck somewhere here I
was a DNF student you know what DNF
students get from other parents rolling
eyes judgment and condescending comments
but my mom raised the biggest winner in
that high school so how are you is doing
these value you'll keep right now what
are you actually doing listening they're
five and eight I'm listening we have
four and nine great I'm listening I've
made zero judgments so far on how I'm
doing that I am just watching them the
way you become a great parent and put
your child in a position to succeed is
you build the roadmap and the blueprint
in reaction to who they are not your
personal ideological wants and needs I'm
watching them I'm seeing what comes
natural to them what they love and what
they don't love what they're good at
what they're not good at and then I will
create supportive infrastructure around
that but right now pure love and pure
support while deep lines in the sand of
what is humanly right and wrong being
nice is a line in the sand trying to
form some resemblance of compassion and
empathy is a line in the sand you can't
I don't know how much you can instill
empathy and compassion but I'm trying to
in a subtle way those are things that I
care about I do not give a [ __ ] about
what
grade-level they're reading at or I'm
not overthinking that they're a little
spoiled
you can't fabricate environment I grew
up with nothing
they're growing up with something I'm
not gonna be able to trick that what am
I not gonna buy them a toy while they're
going to the Hamptons for the summer
like you know you know you don't you
don't fabricate environment so I'm in
the listening business right now so we
massive on gratitude and we try and take
that with our children you've many ways
we can yes whether that be on the way to
school
give me five things that you're breaking
for today that's right you know if those
kinds of things getting into their heads
yes yes what are you doing because
you're the king of rights you believe
the theme and no but you've paid that
we'd slip the price honesty which is
just yeah I don't get awesome come on I
think you know look I'm in a great spot
like I don't do anything my kids are
gonna watch my youtube videos very soon
yeah this is already done like it's an
ethos it's a living like I think the
tactics matter and I respect the but I'm
not I'm not giving that but I do think
it's a good idea yeah like I think
that's clever and when you were just
saying are like all [ __ ] I should do
that but I won't because that's not what
I do
everybody needs to do what they do but
I'm doing it you know as you know to me
what scares me is when somebody does
tactics and doesn't live it if you're
actually grateful then that tactic is
phenomenal it's a reinforcer but if
you're not and you're doing it as an
optic which is what so many parents do
parents do a lot of things they don't
believe in they do what they think
they're supposed to be doing and they
get caught up in a rat race of I'm
telling you this is what I would took me
until I was one but even more
importantly until I spent time with a
lot of them now that I have kids I spend
time with it I'm like here's a good one
do you know that I didn't really
understand why parents put bumper
stickers on their cars of the
universities that their kids went to I
didn't realize that that was something
that made them feel good about
themselves look at me I'm the parent of
a kid that went to Princeton the thought
for me to have my self-esteem wrapped up
in my kids accomplishments is so foreign
I think that's a loser
yes
just ego it's just ego and it's
insecurity and it's trying to paint a
picture and so to me you know I Know Who
I am as a human and what my values are
and how I think people like how I would
you know here's what I'm thinking about
I it's less about what I'm gonna do it's
more about what I'm going to do in
reaction to so and I'm a unique
situation I over index with young kids
because of my style so you know my kids
are only 7 or 10 years away from their
friends thinking I'm cool yeah and when
you know when your friends think
something's cool you think it's cool so
I'm gonna have a bigger impact on my
kids through the eyes of their friends
and what that means to them my kids are
gonna listen to me more because their
friends listen to me then them listening
to me and he's all over it where did
that come from how cuz we use it all the
time we've done so I wish I was on a
flight I'll never forget it that was
outside of an airport I was on a flight
and two people in a row DM to me
something on instant I'm a listener I'm
a counter-puncher you know I'm a very
interesting character I'm confusing
because I talk all the time I interrupt
people so everybody thinks all I want to
do is talk but what's interesting is I
spend the majority of my time listening
nobody reads their comments more than me
nobody speaks and adjusts on the fly
based on how the audience is reacting
more than me nobody does that like I
believe in that in me I think that's
what so I'm listening so what happened
I was listening I read two separate
emails or DMS or Twitter post of like
some insecurities from two of my
audience members something hit me of
like of a scene of like this is like I
hear it all the time but something in
those two in a row got me motivated I
got off the airplane and I was like
let's film this and I just happen to see
a dumpster and thought it was a funny
scene and you know referenced trash and
highschool like just had a moment you
know I have the a lot of times I know
when
I can't predict virality but I always
know when I have something in me if I
can get them to film at that it's going
to do well so we're working long hours
you're working long hours how do you
feel guilty that if you're not being you
know I'm not going to do things open I
feel guilty and what would you say to a
parent that may be feeling guilty that
they're not able to get to all the
school play I would tell the owner I
would tell them who gives a [ __ ] of what
garyvee thinks and you do you yeah you
live your life I'm just a little
practical about this I think it's more
important to love your child
unconditionally and support them than to
be at every event so a lot of parents go
to every event but they're undermining
their children's happiness and
self-confidence because they themselves
are insecure so to me it's just checking
a box so what you're a big shot cuz you
went to every Little League game but
meanwhile you're an alcoholic or you're
insecure and you're trying to suppress
your child or do you tell them that they
can't do or you make them over practice
baseball because it makes you feel good
if they get a scholarship around
baseball so I'd much rather miss every
other play and recital and ball game but
make my kids emotional ninjas that's my
choice on this issue and so is my wife
to be honest so now you're [ __ ] off
to the races right yeah because people
listening to me
I'm penetrating like I you know why cuz
I'm speaking the truth
you and I are we're doing the show right
now I'm bringing up the maddox and
parenting that I'm struggling to see
people talk about because I'm getting to
the part that nobody wants to talk about
the truth the truth is you're struggling
with parenting cuz it's all about you
you know my parents are you're saying
that you want your kid to be
well-rounded and so they're in violin
and sports in this app but it's because
you want to go cycling and have a coffee
with your girlfriends that's the truth
yeah so either we're gonna talk about
the truth or not you're saying that
you're gonna pay well what a great dad I
am I'm sending Ricki to the best
baseball camp this year and I'm working
hard to pay for it you like bragging
that little Ricky's a great [ __ ]
baseball player it's selfish I'm just
not about that
not with my audience it's about them and
definitely obviously not with my kids it
is about them and I'll get mine in the
residuals my mom is like walking around
like a like my mom and I talk every
other morning every morning everything
you know sometimes I can go a week
without talking to her so it's not even
like you know it's not like this cliche
I talk to my mom every day we're talking
I'm talking my mom right now like we're
like that you understand and when I talk
to her every day she just like she just
thinks it's the grade she's like like
she's like all these mom all these
Russian moms are hitting me up and you
know like she's like she's getting like
everything gets paid off properly she is
an all-time mom and I was meant to be
somebody who has an audience who that
gets to tell everybody she was an
all-time mom and that's a big deal so
many people and and it's been really
common thread through successful people
that we've spoken to that they've had
these foodie Kiku's you know child or
teenage years and then struggle well
I'll tell you what none of that I'll
tell you what I think people sometimes
search to create an origin story
I think people fabricate their struggles
yeah cuz it's romantic and I also think
it's in the edges I think you either are
very much struggling but I think there's
a lot of people who are very successful
who have remarkable high school years
yeah and I'm one of them and I think I
there's a lot of people as I'm talking
to you I'm thinking about a lot of kids
who a lot of times in immigrant families
because when you have a tight family
that's really a big factor who had great
childhoods and are crushing it because
they're blindly self-confident I'm
blindly stuck up my mom brainwashed me
into believing I'm the best and I just
believe I really believe it like I I in
a world of blond musk and Mark
Zuckerberg and Jeff Bezos and Mark Cuban
and and all these incredible
entrepreneurs in a world of that
and an incredible executives like Sheryl
Sandberg and Arianna Huffington in a
world of that I'm completely utterly
convinced as I said here with you today
that I will be the Alpha winner of this
generation because I won't make the most
money but I will have make but I will
make the most money and impact most
people you can't you can't win this
thing without both I can be quite fluffy
and amazing and make everybody but if I
didn't have the business success well
then no you wouldn't look up to me that
way yeah but I think I'm gonna win so we
looks like you're having the best one
ever so what's the most fun part about
what you do and what's the toughest man
they're one in the same I'm the most fun
and the toughest part is I was built for
the masses yeah I was built to be Who I
am
I am absolutely gonna have 100%
awareness in the world everybody on this
world as long as I don't die too young
for some reason in 40 years every person
on this earth will know who I am I was
built for that there are very few people
that achieve that I will achieve it and
it's there's a lot of reasons there's a
lot of people who are uber famous before
that weren't known in Africa or Asia
because of the way media worked before
the way media works now I will be known
everywhere that's the best and most fun
but it's also the hardest because when
you are for everyone it takes away from
what you have left for yourself and your
family that's it that is my gift than my
curse and I know it and you know you
kind of like you know it's not like you
let go of the steering wheel but
sometimes you just understand it so but
I don't beat myself up about it because
a parent's job is to put their what is
the binary line of being a parent put
your kid in the best position to have a
happy and healthy successful life that
is not showing up to every one of their
events what are we talking about here
people playing in the [ __ ] [ __ ]
we're treating on the [ __ ] we're
talking about commodity stuff
no kids gonna need you if the parrot was
playing in the
clouds parents are playing in the dirt
my new shot and it's all predicated
about them listening if you watch your
child for seven years and you're
obsessed about that you know your
parents parent all three of their kids
the same way they're not crazy that is
yeah so it's all about selfishness and
insecurity at the payer level so I'm not
gonna concede to the current state of
political correctness it's not going to
be considered politically correct in
three years you know me you know me
parents are drawing a line in the sand
that I'm not gonna reward this bad
behavior and they think like that's the
most important thing without realizing
how this actually all works
why are a lot of rich kids spoiled and
shitty and wire a lot of rich kids like
you can't believe that they're super
rich and have it was the parent it was
the framework it was the experience it
was the environment if there's a million
variables that go into it
parents are beating themselves up like
they're judging themselves gotta go look
way bigger than that like I loved
debating this with parents because I'll
win every time here's why we're
selective like any parent that's like
listening rounds like you're wrong about
that garum like ooh let's sit down and
talk and let me spend one hour
tell me everything I'm like well you you
don't you don't feed your kids very well
and that might be somebody else's number
one I'm like wait you you let your kids
drink soda every day that's somebody
else's you've got to read well that's
somebody like everyone right there's
like 47 things that people think is the
most music yeah a [ __ ] yes again great
but I know a ton of parents who make
their kids do music so that they have to
be with an instructor so they can go do
something it's not that they believe the
musical skill set will set them free
yeah it's just that it's just an
emotional game it's not a physical game
and so to me it's just getting kids in
the right mindset teaching them very
basic things like kindness and gratitude
and and work ethic what about household
tools like yeah I mean again again would
never judge somebody else thinking
that's important
but again it's a tactic it's like to me
it's the next step which is like yes but
like I'm not scared to rip off the
band-aid one can say gradually get them
into being a 14 year old that has a job
and chores help them I actually agree
with that that makes sense I'm also not
scared of buying them everything in the
world and then walking in on their
fourteenth birthday and saying and that
by the way 14 is an arbitrary number it
could be 13 could be 16 the picking some
moment that I feel good about and saying
I'm not giving you [ __ ] and now you work
and they'd be like you [ __ ] me because
you know you gave me everything but I
know that if I can do that somewhere two
to three years before of college four
years before a college boring college
that they'll be on their way they just
have to know that they have to do to get
what they want and to me I don't mind if
I screwed them or if I gradually put
them into it because guess what in life
both are gonna happen in life you'll
have 40 when you lose a parent some
people lose their parent hello and your
sibling crying mom died right the others
mom gets diagnosed and takes four and a
half years in life
some things are gradual some things are
sudden so to me it's just preparing all
these parents trying to prepare their
kids for life by touching everything and
anything everything and it's so [ __ ]
its up everybody who's a parent right
now will go down generally in a hundred
years will be viewed upon as the worst
generation of parents in the history of
mankind we are doing a terrible
collective job and there are hundreds of
millions of millions of phenomenal
parents unfortunately the global and
obviously this is not the case in
Venezuela this is not the case in Syria
but globally things have been very good
for the last 50 to 60 70 years world war
two is a long time ago the Black Plague
is a long time ago right yeah it's a
long time ago
we have prospered as a race for so long
that it is now forced parents to care
about things that don't actually matter
it's not the parents so I'm not mad at
the current parents it's the macro
effect of prosperity our
great-grandparents
we're good at parenting because they
didn't have time to worry about
playdates
they were worried about bombs dropping
on ads they worried about the depression
they were worried about different things
if you're a third generation Australian
or American para you're Eastern European
Western Europe parent on a macro there's
a lot of good so you've now gotten into
the [ __ ] third generation of
prosperity so that means we're soft yeah
that's real here's what I would say I
would never tell anybody had a parent
period let's start with I've been doing
that through this whole conversation let
me make everybody understand we're just
I'm answering your question yeah I have
zero interest in telling how somebody to
parent here's what I would say there's
enough in the system right now to show
that the way we've kind of been doing it
for the last 15 or 20 years has some
cracks in the armor I parents would
rather blame social media for suicide
than the macro parenting trends you know
why didn't kids used to not why the kids
don't use to not have suicide be such an
issue well it's because we treated
bullying and winning and using
differently let me tell you what 1974 us
told their kids when they got bullied at
school deal with it what are we doing
we're in it which makes them feel like
they can't handle it now do I think us
parenting is the only reason there's
suicide rates up of course not there's a
million variables modern medicine diet
information but it's not social media
like and we want to keep demonizing new
technologies because we don't want to
face our own issues so what I would say
is I scrutinize myself as a parent every
day and I don't think enough people are
doing that you know I think we want to
say it's anybody but our fault
responsibility yeah 100% your kids
struggling right now in something that's
your fault yeah whether it's his or her
fault whether it's somebody else's fault
it's a great strategy to think it's
yours whether it's true or not yeah so
you gotta go ty let's say two minutes
let's say I'm a teenager
yes and my parents have lit me we know
better she yes let me know stop blaming
them because that's what every teenager
is running I get every deal yeah my
parents [ __ ] me they made it so eat I
love this they made it so easy for me
like my parents [ __ ] me they make it
so easy for me now I'm struggling I'm
like okay like deal with it we're
training teenagers like three-year-olds
instead of like we're going down instead
of up hey Sally 14 years old from you
know the Gold Coast you know like you
that's what happened here's a lot of
other things that happened yeah you're
pretty you're good at sports you're not
pretty you're not good at sports
you're gonna math you're bad a bat like
it's your life so now what you can spend
all your energy dwelling and blaming or
you can realize that if you're capable
of taking on responsibilities and going
forward right now you will win in life
now that's heady [ __ ] for a 15 year old
cuz I you know I see it go over their
head plenty of times but here's my point
that's the right answer and more
importantly if one out of every four of
them take it you're making an impact I
think we this is the difficulty for you
guys making a message consumable to more
usually means that it's not impacting
anyone yep this is the if you ask me
what I would without knowing anything
about you what would be my intuition
that if you said hey come and analyze us
I would say without knowing anything
because it's 99.9% of what's happening
in the world as you go through it
everybody tries to find that Mendoza
line that can affect as many people as
possible without realizing that then it
gets to vanilla and it's not doing what
they want for anybody I'd rather
impact one out of every 17 teenagers to
meaningfully change that zero out of 17
by pandering and wavering in a couple
places to make it seem more consumable
it's tough you see where I'm going
yeah and so what I would tell you is go
even further go one step further
whatever you believe in that you're
milking down go harder because the only
reason you're not is you're worried
about what's coming back where you when
you go there and it can come in a
million ways they won't get it which is
nice to think or who that would be tough
for parents to hear or tough for kids to
hear it like it's one or the other I
think that's the truth
your truth in your opinion at its
strength is its purest form not watered
down with Oliver half daring to the
gratitude that is full like so much it
is bursting out we want to thank you
thank you guys for this time thanks for
having me
thank you for having us no ace there
that goalie thank you you got it
[Music]